joining us now with more on this
decision is the Orange County California
under Sheriff Don Barnes's with a sir
first I want to applaud you secondly I
kind of took what your attorney general
out in California said as a threat in
other words he wouldn't
almost insinuating he might try to
arrest you for just putting out who's in
jail and when they got him released
isn't that legal well it is completely
legal it's under the under the law that
was passed under Senate bill 54 there
was a provision that says what we
clearly cannot do which we cannot
communicate with immigrations and
Customs Enforcement but it says we can
make this information available if we
make it available to the public which is
exactly what we've done yesterday so we
are following the law and we have an
obligation to follow the law doesn't the
state of California when you have an
Oakland mayor again the the ice ice was
trying to enforce laws against criminal
illegal immigrants those that committed
other crimes beyond that which was not
respecting our laws and sovereignty if I
were to give people a warning that you
were about to go in and hold them
accountable for crimes would I be aiding
and abetting and obstructing justice
well potentially but that I think that
would be a little bit of a stretch this
is what we are very clearly doing we're
going after very serious offenders who
are in custody of our jail under being
convicted of some very serious crimes SB
54 allows us to notify ice on those that
were under the trust Act which was
passed in 2014 a previous previously
passed legislation and that's what we're
doing we're still notifying Isis Europe
has that discretion last year we turned
over 580 we had 57,000 bookings so
that's a small percentage or actually
just 58,000 this year we've already
turned over 181 but two hundred
forty-four individuals were not turned
over to ice and that's what we're
concerned about so they're very serious
crimes and they're being returned back
into the community and quite honestly
back to the communities in which they
preyed upon and committed their crimes
to begin with so we're trying to help
the community be safer by turning these
into
over to ice and not linen they returned
to the communities in kit Mart commit
more crime do you have a response to the
Attorney General and the comments that
he made tonight was I I took them as a
little threatening towards you well they
were threatening but I would say my hope
would be that he would leave read the
language of the law that was passed it
very clearly says in there what we can
and cannot do we cannot communicate with
with eyes which is in and of itself a
challenge it's returning us back to a
pre 911 condition legislatively where we
can't talk with other federal law
enforcement agencies and that's
problematic on its face but it's also
has a provision where we can't make this
information available publicly its
information and made available publicly
and every inmate within our custody of
the jail who has a sentence expiration
date not those who are here illegally
every inmate in our care has that
information posted online so we're not
needing anybody anybody can go sift
through that information find out who's
here
sure and if he does do anything I
promise you I will do everything in my
power to help mobilize people to assist
and help you in any way we can thank you
for standing up for the rule of law